ついにこの日が来てしまったか…
とりあえず…
打ち上げの準備をしておこう
もしもし
今日暇？
ねぇ、待って、今からさあ
ちょっと、卒業できるかどうか確認するからさ
ひょっとしたら今日打ち上げになるかもしれないからね
わかった、じゃあね
はーい、じゃあね
いやー、怖いなー
よーし…
やるか！
うお、うお、うお、あ、痛い
こんにちわ、大学生のはじめしゃちょーです
さぁ、いよいよこの時が来てしまったな…
まぁ、僕は決して
結果はどうだっていいんですよ
僕はやることやりました
大学生活最後のテストの
成績の結果を今から見ます
もう実は見れたんですけど
ネットで成績確認するための
アカウントのIDとパスワードを全部忘れちゃって
学校に行って無事IDとパスワードをゲットしたので
皆さんに言いました。
結果はちゃんと動画で言うと僕は言ったんで
ちょっと今から、僕が大学を卒業できるかどうかがわかります
なんかよく「２ちゃんねる」とかで、俺見るからな！
「２ちゃんねる」で、俺、見たぞ！
「２ちゃんねる」で、
「２ちゃんねる」で留年系YouTuberとか
留年１回もしてない。
イギリスに留学とかね、その
留学関係で1年遅れたんですけど、
留年は一度もしてません。
一応ちゃんとやることはやりましたからね
できればこのままストレートで出たい
まぁ、留年したらしたでおいしい…
いや、おいしくない！
おいしくないよ
出たいよ　一発で
卒業論文はクリアしましたと。
で、授業
僕、二つ取ってて
ポルトガル語と英語のコミュニケショーンのやつがあったんです
その二つの成績が取れれば、単位が足りて
卒業できるという感じでございます
はぁ〜、待って、本当に怖い
一応ね、評価が４つあるんですけど
この5種類があるんですけども
ま、不可じゃなければ、とりあえずいけます
やべぇ、手足が震えてきたぞ
パスワードあります
あれ？入れなくね？そんなバカな。
入れた
いや〜、マジだよ、マジ、マジ、マジ、
マジでこれ決まっちゃうよ
ヤバい、本当に手足が震えてきた
成績情報
あ、待って待って！本当に待って！
マジで怖い！
手汗が！手汗が！(焦)
あ、わかんねーやww
あ、えー、ふーっ。
成績情報だよね
年別単位か
待って待って待って待って待って待って待って
まだ入らない
落ち着け。英語のコミュニケーションの成績から見ていきましょう
結果です
よっしゃーーーーーーーー！！！！！
YES！YES！
よっしゃ！取りました！
よっし！
(電話が鳴る)
もしもし〜？
お疲れっす〜。お疲れっす〜。
あの、卒業できるかどうか確認してるんで
ひょっとしたら今日、祭りかもしんないっすよ
わかった、早く早く早く来て
はい、遊戯王、遊戯王カードちゃんと持ってね。
遊戯王カードちゃんと持って来て
#@&%"*="$%,
じゃ、お気をつけて、あー、お疲れ〜。
#$%&"#$%*#$%$&$Y$#%'&%#Y%
ファイナルビッグアタックチャンシングメンソレータムゲンタムチャンプオンデマンド
はい、次、行きましょう！
英語の、結果は
Sまではいかなかったんですけども
よしっ！よしっ！よしっ！
待って待って。次だぞ、問題は。
さあ次でございます。
ポルトガル語。
もうギリギリまで頑張って覚えたんで
ポルトガル語、確認していきましょう
あ、待って。本当に頼む。
やったーーーーーー！！！
やったーーー！
取れてた！やったーーーー！！
良かった〜。
取れてたーーーーー。
待って待って、本当に？
待って！マジで言ってんの？
先生、ありがとうございます
やったー。
待って待って待って
ま、一応これで、今回受けたテストはしっかり取れてたという事がわかりました
待って。大事なのはここからでございます
よく僕は聞くんですよ、大学生で。
単位は取って、卒業できると思ってたけど
実は単位が足りなかったみたいなパターンが
あるとよく聞いたんで、俺の中では卒業できてる。
今は。
卒業要件、要件合計が、必要単位が合計126。
僕が取得した単位は135！
オーバー126！
卒業！
いえーーーーーーーー！
やったーーーーーーー！！
待って！これ、完璧に来たしょ！
おっしゃー！
もう大学バレてもいいや。
なんかこんな感じでですね、
まぁ、結構オーバーして全部取ったという訳でございます
皆さん、
宣言した通り、僕はやってやりました！
ははっ。ちょっと待って。
なんか言う事ねぇな。
なんだろうなぁ。
あ〜、本当に大学生終わっちゃうんだなぁ。
長かった学生生活が、これで一先ず終わり、
これから僕はカリスマ二…
映像関係で、こう、何かやっていければなと
実は思っていまして、ま、一先ず、
ま、一先ずね、Youtubeは楽しいですよ
という訳で学生の皆さん、
大変だとは思いますが
何故僕がこんなに卒業に
執着心があるのかと言いますと
高いお金を親から払って
危ないな…。
親からいただいて
通っている訳でございます
なんか、すぐ泣いちゃうから、すっごい嫌だ、俺。
くそー。
いやぁ、中学も高校もね、大学も！
学校に行けてるのは全て、親のおかげです
けじめかなと思いまして
頑張らせていただきました
よくね、学校辞めるって人、よく聞くんですけど
それはそれでいいと思います
多分、いろいろね、辛いこととかね、
やりたい事とか
考えた結果がそれに行ったんで
ま、それはそれでいいと思うんですけど
僕は…
ま、親が頑張って
親が頑張って働いたお金で行かせていただいていると思っているんで
もう何が何でも、絶対卒業してやろうと思って
てか、それがもう約束だったんですよ。
大学に入るね。
絶対に卒業するって約束で僕は大学に行ったんで、
ま、僕は男としての約束を守れたのかなと思います！
はい。これからはカリスマ二…Youtuberとして
いろいろな事をやっていければいいなと思っとります！
じゃあな！！！